♪
>> DEMOCRATIC OREGON GOVERNMENT
ARE PUSHING RACIAL EQUALITY OVER
GETTING A QUALITY EDUCATION
AFTER SHE QUIETLY SIGNED A NEW
BILL THAT GETS RID OF MATH,
READING, AND WRITING
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TO GRADUATE.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS IT WILL
HELP STUDENTS OF COLOR, BUT
SHE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF DUMBING
DOWN SCHOOLS TO MPS FAR LEFT
LIBERALS.
DANA, I THINK THIS IS A TRAGEDY
FOR EVERYBODY BECAUSE YOU'RE
LOWERING THE STANDARDS RATHER
THAN THINKING KIDS COULD RISE TO
THE CHALLENGE.
>> TO MEET ITS CHILD ABUSE AND
AS A TAXPAYER I'M MAD BECAUSE
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS NOT
GOOD ENOUGH.
HOW MUCH MONEY I DON'T LIVE IN
OREGON SO I DON'T PAY STATE
TAXES THERE, BUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALSO KICKS IN.
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY WENT
FOR COVID RELIEF.
WE ARE BASICALLY PAYING KIDS TO
NOT ACTUALLY MEET STANDARDS OR
I'M SORRY, PAYING THESE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DO THAT, AND I
THINK OUR NATIONAL
COMPETITIVENESS IS AT GREAT
RISK, THAT MEANS OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY IS AT RISK AND WHAT
KIND OF LIFE ARE YOU SUBJECTING
THESE PEOPLE AND THEIR PARENTS
TOO.
YOU THINK PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE A
BETTER LIFE THAN THEIR PARENTS
IS THE AMERICAN DREAM, IF YOU
DUMBED DOWN STANDARDS AS BADLY,
YOU WILL GET EXACTLY WHAT YOU
PAY FOR.
I DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR IT
ANYMORE.
>> IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
PARENTS ASKING FOR THE STANDARDS
TO BE LOWERED, IT SEES ACTIVIST
TO PRESSURE THE MAYOR AND NOT
JUST OREGON, IN FAIRFAX,
VIRGINIA THEY JUST DID THIS TO
YOU BY GETTING READY OF AP
ENGLISH IN AP CLASSES BECAUSE
THEY SAY IT WAS UNFAIR.
YOU THINK YOUR KID SHOULD HAVE
STANDARDS FOR EXCELLENCE?
>> TO BE CLEAR, THIS IS OUT OF
RACIAL POLITICS OF THIS ISN'T
ONLY A TRAGEDY AND NOT ONLY
CHILD ABUSE, THIS IS RACIST THIS
IS THE IDEA THAT BLACK AND BROWN
CHILDREN CANNOT SATISFY
UNIVERSAL STANDARDS SO WE MUST
LOWER THEM.
THEY SUGGEST THAT SOMEHOW IS
WHITE SUPREMACY.
IT'S LIKE THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MUSEUM PUT IT THAT SAID
PUNCTUALITY, HARD WORK AND
OBJECTIVES THOUGHTS OUR
CHARACTERS OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
NO, THESE ARE THE PATH TO
SUCCESS.
FOR YOU SUGGEST THAT BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS CANNOT LIVE UP TO THE
STANDARDS IS FLAT OUT RACIST.
THIS IS GOING TO THE DOCTOR AND
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY WE'RE GOING
TO GET THE PATIENT IS STILL
SICK, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT YOUR TESTS COME BACK, THESE
KIDS STILL GRADUATE, THEY WILL
STILL BE IGNORANT, THEY WON'T BE
ABLE TO SATISFY THE STANDARDS
AND LIFE WILL PUNISH THEM FOR
THAT.
>> JESSICA?
>> I DON'T LIKE IT.
THERE HAS TO BE A BETTER WAY AND
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO SAY THIS
EVERY BLOCK, SOME TERRIBLE THING
HAPPENS A POLICE OFFICER BEING
KILLED OR AN UNARMED PERSON
BEING KILLED AND WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THESE SCHOOLS, IT'S EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING AS SOMEONE WHO DOES
BELIEVE IN THE CAUSE OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND THINK
CHILDREN WHO HAVE GROWN UP IN
HOMES BLACK, WHITE BROWN,
WHEREVER IT IS WHERE THEY FACE
SYSTEMIC CHALLENGES AND NEED A
HELPING HAND DESERVE THAT, THAT
WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT A BETTER
WAY.
WHEN I WAS READING ABOUT THIS
AND SAID WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE SYSTEM FOR A YEAR SO THAT WE
CAN LOOK UNDER THE HOOD, YOU
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO LOOK UNDER
THE HOOD AT THE SAME TIME THAT
KIDS ARE STILL GOING TO BE
TAUGHT AT AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL
SO THEY CAN QUALIFY TO GO ON
WITH THEIR LIVES WHETHER THAT
MEANS GOING TO AN
APPRENTICESHIP, GOING TO
COLLEGE, GOING TO JUNIOR
COLLEGE, WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> ISN'T THE LEFT WALKING
STUDENTS, PARTICULARLY STUDENTS
OF COLOR INTO THESE PRISONS AND
GIVING THEM A LIFELONG SENTENCE
BECAUSE PARENTS IN THE INNER
CITIES ARE TRYING TO GET THE
KIDS INTO CHARTER SCHOOLS SO
THEY CAN ACHIEVE THESE THINGS
AND GET A SCHOLARSHIP TO
COLLEGE, THIS KIND OF ENSURES
THAT NONE OF THEM WILL QUALIFY.
>> EIGHT GUARANTEES THE FIRST
STEP INTO A COMPETITIVE LIFE,
YOU'RE ALREADY IN THE NEGATIVE.
IT'S LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE IS
GOING TO BE BETTER OFF THAN YOU
ARE, AND IT'S AN ASSESSMENT ON
THIS IDEA OF EQUITY, WHICH IS
NOT ABOUT THE FREEDOM TO
ACHIEVE, BUT TO INSTALL CEILING
TO ACHIEVEMENT.
IT'S LIKE SOCIALISM, IT IS A
CRUSHING LIMIT FROM ABOVE THAT
SAYS ALL OF YOU WILL BE STUPID
TOGETHER.
IF YOU GUYS CAN'T DO MATH, AND
YOU GUYS CAN'T DO MATH, BUT YOU
CAN DO MATH, NO, NO ONE IS DOING
ANY MATH, WE COULD TEACH YOU
GUYS MATH, BUT WE PREFER ALL OF
YOU TO BE IGNORANT IN MATH.
THERE'S A GUY ON TWITTER, CORY
DEANGELIS, HE HAS LED THE CHARGE
ON THE NEW TREND OF ALLOWING
PARENTS TO TAKE THEIR EDUCATION
DOLLARS EVERYWHERE, ELSEWHERE,
ABOVE THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
SCHOOL CHOICE OBVIOUSLY, AND WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
IMPROVING REMOTE LEARNING.
I THINK THAT'S THE WAY TO GO.
IT IS WHAT PELLA TAUNTED TO THE
GYM.
>> I WANTED TO ADD ONE OTHER
THING.
THE DEMOCRATS DROP THE BILL
YESTERDAY TO HEAD 3.$5 TRILLION
IN SPENDING INTO OTHER THINGS
INCLUDED AND THERE ARE FREE
PRE-K FOR EVERYBODY, AND FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW, IF
PEOPLE CANNOT PASS A BASIC
STANDARD TEST TO GET OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL, I DO NOT WANT TO PAY FOR
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THERE SHOULD AT LEAST BE SOME
STANDARDS AND IF THIS
MONSTROSITY PASSES, THE
REPUBLICANS AT LEAST OUGHT TO
INSIST ON THOSE STANDARDS.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
PEOPLE WOULD LOVE THEIR TAX
DOLLARS TO GO TO A SUPER TOUGH
SCHOOL IF THAT MAKES EVERYBODY
SMART.
WE ARE SPENDING MORE MONEY PER
STUDENT THAN ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD, AND WE ARE NOT DOING
ANYTHING.